hello everyone welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car I'm Alana
PS today I'm joined by Monty sleep
everybody and also Anthony Carboni
what's up well hello where do people
know your goodness I'm on the the star
wars show every Wednesday in Star Wars
calm never heard of it I also yeah it's
a small scrappy upstart series of films
that I think are gonna take off any day
now
and then I do a podcast with Jeff kanata
every Wednesday it's a science comedy
podcast called we have concerns you guys
do like a lot of kind of carnival
commentary stuff too right no I try to
keep Jeff away from as much current
because he's old in his heart as weak
and she just gets he gets riled up it's
all worked up and then he has to sleep
for 17 to 20 hours yeah if he dies it'll
work yeah it's just you having concerns
which I do I have concerns about I have
concerns that's my favorite my concerns
about Jeff it is hell yeah that's very
sweet
we don't talk about anything that's
hafiz impressive as science or current
events and prevention of heart attack I
would say all the things that you talk
about our current events I would say
these these more than anything show they
they've got their finger on the pulse of
the zeitgeist this is who people are I
have learned a lot about society by
reading misconnections a lot wait would
you feel like you've learned more things
that make you feel more positive about
society or more negative about society
no no to both yeah just differently just
interesting like the thing that I find
the most interesting is the amount of
posts it'll like hey not a gay dude
looking to suck a dick not gay not gay
just want to suck a penis and there's a
lot of those and you're like wow that
what does that mean I also feel like I'm
by going through these I've seen a lot
of penises and I feel like I just feel
better about my own I've also seen a lot
of people being like I am very
good-looking don't ask for pitches so
it's like there's definitely a lot of
liars out there I'd like to run a
marathon once in my life but
I don't want to be a marathon runner do
you know what I mean like I want to jump
out of a plane once to see how it goes
but if I live I don't think I would want
to tempt fate again so I get it I want
to suck a dick once just once once just
to know seem to be but they're like hey
totally not gay just looking to have sex
with a man in my shirt that time some of
them refer to each other as friends
they'll be like hey looking for friends
to like have sex with not gay just
buddies have some sex go back to my
wives it's it's fascinating
minigolf after if you're up for it yeah
but like no project no French mostly
just the sex though is the important
thing yeah but not get not gay no all
right Mike do you want to start us off
yes this is a local one from here in LA
its title is all caps help please -
bubbles ah - worked for Pacific Bell in
1972 oh my goodness hey man seeking a
woman I'm trying to find someone who can
confirm the existence of a girl named
bubbles who was working for Pacific Bell
in downtown LA in late 72 early 73 I
don't need to contact her directly and
I'm not trying to disrupt her life this
is not a sexual thing the messy truth of
it is that my kids have heard mention of
this girl's name many many years ago and
based on her name bubbles have jumped
the conclusion that she must have been a
stripper that I was having an affair
with the truth is that she worked in the
same Pacific Bell office that I did for
a short time and I'd never even had a
conversation with her I need to clear my
name please help okay as soon as you
said bubbles in the title I also assume
she guess I'm gonna feel like that's one
of the key elemental stripper names it's
that in Lamborghini how would you spell
Cristal that's important it's like a kr
yyy like Krista Pacific Bell that was a
major phone company that was like the
major West Coast phone that was the 18 T
before he came T on the West Coast like
during the
early nineteen hundred's can I say so
this is my first my first gut feeling
about the clearing the name yeah there's
a weird detail in there where he says
I've never even had a conversation about
her but my kids heard her name all the
time yeah good point
yeah I think the truth is worse it's
better for your kids to think that Oh
dad legitimately had an affair with a
real woman that he knew that knew him
and cared about him as well then dad was
obsessed with this woman he never spoke
to me it's probably also that if you are
having those conversations with your
kids and you're getting defensive enough
that you need to post this listen to be
like I need to clear my name then
they've had arguments about it right
meaning some [ __ ] so they worked here in
72 73 which was almost 50 years ago and
the fact that this guy's in his sixties
assumedly 70s doesn't have his age but
he was probably at least 20 when he
worked here back then so at what point
did he bring her up and his kids who if
six or seven they're like our age
probably like adults like hmm I don't
know I personally don't give a [ __ ] what
my mom and dad were doing 10 15 20 years
before I was born
could this be one of those things that I
have a couple of these with with my
dad's specifically where it's like this
is a thing I don't actually care about
or think but this is how I'm going to
poke at you to do this and it's how I've
been poking at you for the last few
years yeah I'm gonna keep doing it and
you're just gonna get angrier and
angrier because you don't understand
it's a joke yeah absolutely
it's the trolling that is right but it's
it could also be that which is where I
thought you're gonna go with this is
that maybe bubbles is like it it has
been an inside joke damn be like yeah I
work through someone named bubbles and
something he's like made up this dumb
character and it's like become like a
running joke like yeah it's like he
never actually spoke to her didn't know
it but like brought her up enough as a
joke that it became a thing that they
recognized whenever he mentioned both
you know dad's got schtick he's got
patter about vodka he's got like a tight
5 on bubbles yeah all right
yeah but what like there is no universe
that this yields success okay one point
if her name is actually bubbles that
narrows it down quite a bit there is
also something to like the fact that I
need to find her I need to clear my name
that also shows like even if his kids
are like making fun of him for this
there is something underneath where he
still feels compelled to find this woman
beyond interesting point I like this is
an excuse for him to try and find yeah
as opposed to just being dismissive him
being like you all don't know what
you're talking about haha very funny dad
had an affair no there is something
underneath that that he is still not
admitting to himself 50 years later
about this woman that he is stuck on I
mean it's insane because like I think
back to my first job which was probably
did 15 years ago or so and I don't
remember anyone I worked a single person
like I don't remember the name of anyone
who worked at that grocery store like I
think one girl was cute and I think I
had a crush on did you're better than
all those people at the grocery store my
probably on my side my first job which
was McDonald's is now like in the
gamedev seen in the city that I was
wrong so like I completely forgotten his
name and then found him again via
Twitter because he's now making video
games I was like oh that's [ __ ] like
there was like a looped back around up
to ten years
it's crazy you know Australia does the
McFlurry Machine work yeah [ __ ] you know
Australia shake machine yeah that thick
shake Simon don't McDonald's not no
cheeks I think like a thick shake is
what you call a malt yeah I had the
fixing makes me uncomfortable thick
shake is what I call my wife I'm not
supposed to bring that up alright so the
kids are they're jumping yeah but
they're jumping to assume she's a
stripper meaning they're like 20 makes
me think there really is a kewpie there
are no kids this is a cover story
falsified everything about this is the
story that he felt like what's a story
that I can
type that doesn't make it that doesn't
make me seem super emotionally
vulnerable about a woman that I knew 40
years ago it can't get over
administration this is yeah this is
total cover story of a man who does not
know he can just come out there and be
emotionally brave and say I've been
thinking about this woman my whole life
yeah well I think if that's the case
then he literally hasn't had a
conversation with her because she would
be able to recognize that you know we
spoke all the time what the [ __ ] should
just be offended so he's been doing that
the whole time about a woman he never
spoke to that he worked with for two
years
you think he's gonna kill it I was gonna
say is that sweet well depends on how
you feel about John Cusack movies like
is he a stalker or is he the sweetest
man holding up that boom box playing
Peter Gabriel sweet or is it like call
the police the police it depends on how
she feels about him does she remember
him we don't know the funniest thing
about [ __ ] like this is this scenario
like this will no longer exist now like
moving forward yeah I need to find
anyone I've known in the past 15 years I
could find them except for the one girl
went off the grid yeah the one that got
her dead find this girl Marty so her
hand no give me your hand
you have to find her so the thing about
this you have to find knows that right
right yeah so before I told this on the
show before actually before Zach and I
ever knew each other before he worked at
IGN we both lived in the mission mm-hmm
and we both went to the same bar okay
she was the bartender at the same time
and we both fell in love with her
separately and we both knew that her dad
created gargoyles but then she went off
the great
she has no social media presence not had
her phone number but our plan who's put
an RSS feed on her dad the creator of
gargle so that when he passes away now I
will go to the funeral and one of us
will win her in marriage I don't see any
flaw with this this is actually very
good yeah this is actually a very smart
player Goyal's the movie is called Fargo
Al's that makes it sound like she's a
guard girl she wasn't she was the most
beautiful girl ever her favorite game of
all time is grim fandago she had a han
Solo blaster tattoo you know they can
you know they can you ever see tales
from the darkside it was very cool
there's a cool gargoyle a the
be tales from the darkside the movie an
artist falls in love gets attacked by a
gargoyle right but then falls in love
with this woman and they get married
they have kids that's whole thing and
she's like you can never like ask me
like how we met that night or you could
never like blah blah
you can't look into like how we thought
and the moment he does it turns out she
was a gargoyle
she was the gargoyle that attacked him
she was hot and then they had two kids
but like after he like digs into her
past like whatever spell is lifted and
she turns back into a gargoyle
immediately as do their children she
tears him apart eats him they all fly
away oh and the kids turn the gargoyles
dude that's cool yeah good this is
probably a gargoyle cursed situation we
need to we need it so for every person
we give lemonade yeah Oh Barry Barry
Barry bumbleberry he's gonna you know
bubble Barry all right call Barney
Europe okay this is a short one but it
really it really spoke to me I think it
has levels of weird exodus of local what
is this this is actually from Seattle
okay I've been there it's called I gave
you an accidental back scratch okay I'm
intrigued we were strangers in the 27th
row on a flight from Seattle we didn't
even exchange hellos
you seemed queasy and kept putting your
head on the seat in front of you I was
high on cold medication and decided you
needed a back scratch oh we both
realized what was happening but it was
too late I scratched her back in an
affectionate manner for at least five
seconds and no more no I patted your
back awkwardly at the conclusion of my
back scratch and then pretended to be
asleep if you're reading this I'm sorry
oh my god
so here are the different layers this is
why this appealed to me okay this is why
I wish vine was still around
scratching straight I said I have had to
fly a lot over the last couple years and
there is nothing worse than being sick
on a flight yeah being sick on a flight
when you add like the pressure and the
noise and the being like cooped up in a
tiny seat knowing that you're annoying
everyone by coughing when that clear and
you're trying not to and you can tell
other people and you know like other
people's germs are all up in the mix and
it's just everything is so uncomfortable
just so uncomfortable and so to me there
is there is something in this that is
kind of wonderful in this like very
human moment of like you feel terrible
and I feel terrible and we're in this
together and I am so sorry and just just
like this reflexive action of like I
want you to be okay yeah like I want you
to be okay two sides of john cusack
movie right don't touch me
how do you rub a stranger's back on a
play that's so weird I I feel both sides
of this thing where it's like what my
sweet you seem queasy thing it's like
what if they would just tie it so like
he would be a bad judge of character cuz
he was [ __ ] high on Cody yeah like if
he's high as [ __ ] on it probably was
codeine then man I don't know what I
would do like what would you do if you
did that in someone scratch your back
you know I feel like I would probably
reflexively hit them like I would either
be like what the hell oh like maybe I
would pretend that I was asleep and I
didn't notice yeah so I think if I was
very sick if I was actually legitimately
feeling ill on the plane you could
probably rub my back for a good 30
seconds before something kicked in and I
was like hey this ain't right I flew
alone this isn't my fix a kiss you know
like but for that first 20 seconds I
would be like oh thank god I feel so
terrible thank God somebody noticed I
feel terrible you know I just love but
that I the moment
the turn followed by the prestige is the
hurt looking and being like what and
then him being like oh no what
done pretend you're asleep and I'm like
that's not how it works even like oh
[ __ ] what am I gonna do pretend this
like I've definitely done the thing
where I thought someone was waiting at
me and they want to know oh [ __ ] scratch
me
oh all the time yeah all the time that's
not great that's a big one definitely
never affectionately touch a stranger
accidentally I think I did I did
I touched someone on the shoulder once
because I thought it was like one of my
ex-boyfriends when we were dating I
touched him on the shoulder he was like
oh Rome Carson I'm so sorry
I remember very very vividly in college
running up like just this is this is
like before this is this is like before
I had my ATD meds and any good sense of
like what what how you should act in
public or anything I saw somebody that I
was relatively sure it was this girl in
one of my classes like God like 50 yards
away okay I don't really know this girl
super well but I know I know her from
one of my classes and we've talked and
it's like whatever and so I just think
I'm just gonna do this thing run just
run up on her and [ __ ] scare right
I'm just gonna run up and be like aah
and it's gonna be hilarious what people
saw was this insane person running
across the quad towards her screaming
and grabbing a girl who's like no no I
don't know this girl this was not the
girl in my class this was a stranger I
was like oh my god I am so sorry I
thought you were someone else she's like
how is that appropriate to do to anyone
solid point is for anyone I was just
like oh dear God yeah that's a pretty
bad one I mean I think everyone's had me
like like I've put my hand on someone's
shoulder or like really quickly on small
their back thinking that they were the
person I was dating at the time who was
ended up being five feet away and then
meet Lee I'm so sorry you kind of look
like yes yeah can I tell you something
that is going to flip the script on you
woman rubbing hands back Oh what happens
it's no I think the same I think it's
yes totally does this change the dynamic
for you I mean I just because I assumed
it was a dude being kind of creepy to a
girl I don't think it's creepy like he's
away I didn't think it was creepy it
seems like a human who is compassionate
doing a thing I don't think it's not
sexual at all no and I don't think it's
a sort of thing because it is somebody
who's feeling sick the International
sign for I am sick on an airplane heads
down on the tray table you're kind of
like uh but if you're going to the
neutral zone I feel like the most
neutral zone is probably like between
the shoulder blades and on the shoulder
yeah that's non-sexual yeah that's a
less sexual than like small the back
yeah that's like even if we're if you're
if you're a co-worker of mine and I
don't know you very well but we're gonna
we're in a crowded elevator and I I need
to move you out of the way of somebody
who I can touch your shoulder yeah it's
fine so that's why I think this is this
is clearly this clearly felt like care
taker but I'm not your caretaker I don't
know you we don't know each other huh oh
it's definitely an appropriate
definitely don't do it but I feel like
they had like the fact that they
apologized publicly I'm like hey I
realized when I got off my shitty
codeine high that I did something that
is super inappropriate it's very
handsome now just thinking about the
dude being like what the [ __ ] yeah the
girl being like oh [ __ ]
previously I think it's one of those
things like I said before for the first
15 seconds if I was genuinely sick like
flu sick on an airplane it would
probably happen for 15 seconds before I
realized what was going on then I'd be
like hey whoa whoa yeah whoa not if it's
not you thick shaking shake I don't want
none I want to hear this guy's
perspective though if he's like if he
went home he's like I was sleeping and
this crazy woman she all started
scratching my back and I don't know why
she was doing this and then I looked and
I was gonna say something and then she
pretended to go to bed but I know she
scratched my back like I know we had an
incident she just wouldn't admit I like
the idea that he's not sure if it
actually happened
he's in that one like I I'll have those
moments were like I'm just in that
middle thing I'm like I'm about to fall
asleep but I don't and I just get
startled awake they call that the
devil's brat back scratch what you feel
now what do you feel you're about to
fall asleep that's the devil scratching
your back trying to take you away so did
you wake up yeah you're fine yeah that's
an old that's an old tale from down
south the devil in the middle seat - no
he's looking year and a half ago I try
to compliment a different person every
day so I'll try and like mostly do
people that I kind of jokingly go
complimenting the same person every day
like hey you did really good today or
like your hair or whatever and I tweeted
about this not that long ago and it like
sometimes I will compliment Strange's
and just be like it just like it's very
nice and feels positive and it's a nice
thing like it's uplifting and I had a
lot of people be like that's really
creepy like like be careful what you say
like has anyone ever thought you were
hitting on them the answer is literally
never like I compliment guys just as
much as I compliment women and no one's
ever been like hey let me stop you for a
check like hey man and then they just
like walk and say thanks and
everything's fine people just like a
shoe that it would be totally off limits
and then they couldn't do it yeah I
think that's very odd what happens if I
tell a lady at work I like her new
haircut and then she sends me to HR
never gonna happen yeah there's like
people being like well I told this girl
she had nice tits and she was mad
appropriate I keep scratching people's
backs in the office and they think it's
weird they just seemed like
[Laughter]
God here comes Linda I would love to
work with back-scratching Linda I did
have a teacher in high school teacher
shoulder rub is the most maybe the most
inappropriate type of contact I can
think of that goes on regularly yeah
just gross cuz it's always it's always
some teacher that's like a science
teacher but mostly a track and field
coach who like comes over to some like
lady who's on the team so they like it's
yeah we're teachers student boot we're
also I care about it I'm just gonna
rubbish the [ __ ] the [ __ ] on man
that's a 17 year old girl that is not
alright do you guys watch mine huntin
you know how there's an episode in there
about the feet tickling yeah that was
like a super fascinating episode to me
like you have you seen oh because your
coach would tickle your feet no it's
okay I didn't say it was relatable it's
about this teacher who's like getting
kids into the office and like tickling
their feet and giving them money and
they're like hold up this is [ __ ] up
but no one else is complaining about it
and the parents don't really like doing
anything about it and he's like it's
just my relationship with my kids
nothing bad is happening here and it's
like this weird like struggle about like
it seems very out of place in that show
yeah isn't that a show what's serial
yeah the guy who's like the first guy to
do something really really weird and
like gets away for it with it for awhile
just cuz it's like I mean that's there's
literally there's nothing in the rule
book that says a dog can't play
basketball
this guy's paying kids to tickle their
feet there's like nothing about this
[ __ ] we never thought we'd have to think
about this cuz it's creeps for days
let's all turn to shad on the moon we
make the wall that you can't [ __ ] on the
moon can we do with a problem no we need
to make closing it they have been trying
to design a suit for that and having
trouble with it they've been trying to
figure out how to design suits for like
a long whole space flights in case
something goes wrong gonna have to poop
in their suits what to do with the poop
oh yeah one of the things for I think it
was Mars one they were like they were
gonna fill up giants the you fill up
these sacks with human waste but they
would eventually start insulating the
capsule more and more as you went
because radiation sugar
yeah it's literally like a like [ __ ]
insulation smart but also gross smart
but also gross which is which is what I
would say to Linda here smart but also
gross nice and smart of you to realize
that somebody maybe needed something
gross to go ahead and rub that's a good
call mine is like I was gonna use a
romantic one but I decided against it
because you're afraid of love yeah sided
against it and then you pointed nose was
kind of related to first the feet
tickling and now afraid of love like a
lot is coming out good girl bad morning
that was a Nelly Furtado I saw you this
morning leaving for work you were
arguing with your man friend
he really had you steaming I pulled over
and told you whatever happened let it go
try to have a nice day
I took you it took you a second but you
looked at me and smiled glad I could
help you in the moment open to talking
about what had you so upset and happy to
share a man's perspective hope you have
a nice day
oh that's the goal that's the go away
smile yeah this is Central LA put in
body type average I just think that okay
the the layers to this stood up bad is
like I hate starting with this like it
took you a second but you looked at me
and smile glad I could help you that's
because internally you were like is he
going to murder me I'll smile and maybe
this one I think she probably had no
[ __ ] idea what he even said was just
like thanks bye huh like don't want to
deal with this at all and just keeps
walking and then he's like yeah let me
like let you know what your boyfriend
was thinking in case he couldn't tell
you what he was thinking his part of
this discussion so I've seen actually
like quite a lot of these which is the
discussion I wanted to get into of
people hitting on people that they know
are taking I my rule would be just don't
[ __ ] do a notice of the stances
should you do it but like a lot of
people are trying to consider this and
it's like I know you have a boyfriend
but I'm so interested in you
like I'm going to do this anyway it's
the John Key's our problem it's the
you're in a relationship but man that's
you're just in this relationship cuz you
are and you know you're not being
treated for bad guys around the car I'm
a good guy I'm gonna come in I'm
swooping in right now and I'm gonna be
the hero you're arguing you're arguing
it's clearly a bad relationship nobody
in a good relationship ever argues I'm
here to save you I'm a nice guy [ __ ] you
off dude mind your business yeah good
girl bad morning even that freezing is
just so occurring to a saw you know
anything about this person
yeah get stuck keep the [ __ ] out of it
yes intervene if it's like oh this is
he's gonna hit her your man friend
shaking you by the shoulder cool got out
of my car and said don't shake the
person by their shoulder yeah that's
cool you're being a cool guy saw two
people having a natural like argument
which people do yes pulled over to be
like hey don't let it get to you I'm
real cool and I'm around just [ __ ]
walking by what I wish would have
happened was that the couple who were
having an argument would have just
immediately turned on this dude he like
[ __ ] off mind your own biz just get the
[ __ ] back in your car and someone even
said something nice to me I would be
like I'd prefer if you didn't give this
any attention I'm embarrassed like I
don't want this to be a public thing
like please don't [ __ ] mention it
like even if you're saying something
nice I want to hear it right now yeah
and I mean it's not I love that it
wasn't a pullover to be like are you all
right you didn't even say are you okay
no he's over to be like let it go do you
try to have a nice day so he like sees
who have this shitty thing happen and
then still goes everyone is like I'm
gonna tell you what to do you're
prettier when you smile yeah yeah let it
go you don't know what we were talking
about you don't know this could be this
could be like a very big defining remote
moment of our relationship this could be
something that literally to continually
through my life I cannot let go yeah
[ __ ] you yeah people saying I've had
that said to me like the smile
sweetheart thing that was the one time
that I replied to someone who had said
that I was like my dog died yesterday
and they were like you'll get over it
and I was like and I am this [ __ ]
here but not smiling I'm walking down
the street I was just like my dog died
yesterday
he was like you'll get over like [ __ ]
you man it was like I wasn't crying I
just like obviously looks really unhappy
one day you will learn to smile on
command just like I'm sure that good dog
and then your life will be so much
better I really hate this one but I
always want to like when we tell stories
about the spine like a good thing and
one thing that I might want to compare
it to is the great mystery of girls
bathrooms at clubs so you go into a
women's restroom at a club and it is
like the war zone is gone and women all
love each other and stop being jealous
of each other and nothing is bad
everyone's so supportive there if there
was a girl crying in the soul which
happened to me when we were in Portland
everyone like grabs toilet paper and
like helps her clean on [ __ ] face/off
and like also what happened and like
you're talking about this right you
talking about like a relationship you
don't know anything about no like honey
it's fine you're way too good for him
like you're incredible have you seen
your beautiful have you seen yourself
and the people like touch each other's
boobs and [ __ ] that happens like quite a
bit in women's bathrooms of clubs
someone to be like oh my basics women
and you like fix each other's makeup
it's like the nicest [ __ ] baby
I like that where I like that we are
stuck on two different parts of this
number one Marty is stuck on the wait
there's a lot of boob touching going on
in the app and then mine is I like that
Alana's American accent is just an
Australian accent but through her nose
honey you're fine like don't even worry
about it
you'll totally be fine I love it I know
if I can do it with my belly go
no no Bhama be fine the people of the
United States of America
don't worry about let me have a handful
of that titty
[Laughter]
real I can now you definitely need to
inspect for myself that's really sweet
though
there is a place for like supporting a
complete [ __ ] stranger when they said
I think like it's like the save room in
Resident Evil well it's like there's
hell everywhere outside of here but
there's a typewriter in here there's an
item box listen to some music it's for
organized your organize your knickknacks
and then get back out there get your
shotgun go back out there you know maybe
there is to go back to finding something
nice in this maybe there was this is
somebody who could have had a good
impulse and doesn't know a good healthy
way this is like super condescending is
like someone who doesn't know this
person telling them how to respond to a
situation they don't understand and I
think that's the part that's really
crossed but you're writing that I do
think this is ultimately someone
thinking they are helping someone else
and I think that is a good part of it I
think that they dealt with it the wrong
way and I do think there is a place for
that public argument between two couples
probably never but if one person is like
visibly upset and by themselves and
seems vulnerable I think that I would be
open to having someone approach me if I
looked like just [ __ ] miserable on
the side of a road be like hey you okay
as long as I was like I'm fine basically
yeah I don't think we shouldn't support
strangers but I yeah I don't think help
with the asterisk of like sex maybe it
starts right from the get-go when he
says man friend look that's in my
opinion I always think man friends a
derogatory term for like I don't want to
refer to this person history boy yeah
man friend is this this is some this is
an appendage that can be yeah exactly
his whole thing of let me give you a
man's perspective it'll make you more
perspective on any of this doesn't
matter because you don't know any of the
[ __ ] he's writing and in a bad way yeah
well it's not or he or he's a bad person
but he had a good impulse for once but
he doesn't know how to express it except
for bad you know and hey good luck on
your journey buddy it's good to see that
you are moving forward we wish you all
the best she's getting better
what's this man's name yeah I don't know
what this man's name is bode average at
least he's like
I like body and average body average
height slightly below average even
average this one I feel like is it dude
he's just so [ __ ] smug but he's like
I I would be willing to bet that average
Steven would be like oh she's absolutely
gonna be looking for me average average
Steven was probably like rushing in the
car he's probably going like five miles
over the speed limit the whole way to
work after that because he was like god
I gotta write it cuz she's gonna look no
the second she gets to work she's gonna
look and it better be there cuz like I
don't want to like sleep on this did my
onesie thing she expects me to be there
yeah it's pretty terrible so who has the
highest chance of walking I'm gonna say
bubbles Barry's right at the bottom that
it's then Steven average yeah this is 50
years do you think the bubbles thing is
someone named bubbles which is not
common do you think her real name was
bubbles yeah I do
I mean I guess Pacific Bell if her name
tag said bubbles she was bubbles but
yeah she would have been born in during
World War 2 post-world War II which
debuted as you know at the start of
World War two that was the who's
probably the Steamship the cotton gin
yeah and powerpuff girl Rosie the
Riveter yeah yeah she died like a week
ago the poster girl yeah Wow okay couple
episodes ago I had to I said several
times that I've been for master don't I
want to make it clear once again I've
never made a gas station is that that is
a person that's like oh you're super
[ __ ] easily identifiable yeah like
you know exactly who that button well
you don't forget the mother [ __ ]
scratch your back so here's my thing
about the about
about bubbles and an old bat here is
which who begged Barry buckles and Barry
here's the thing about bottles of Barry
this is like that sort of thing where I
see it in my head as maybe they're both
widowed now Widow and widower and maybe
but maybe there was a thing between them
and maybe it's just like oh yeah I do
remember that guy I think the problem
there barrier is his defensive fake
story yeah yeah that's the barrier yeah
look I need to prove this to my 25 year
old children I think there could be
sweetness underneath you're right but
the means of success for that one is
literally just I don't even need to
contact her I just want someone to
confirm but she exists which is like
that actually seems pretty possible yeah
yeah so I feel like someone's like oh
yeah my neighbor my aunt worked at we're
talking about if we're talking about the
stated goal then yeah that's very easy
right the stated goal on that is very
easy the stated goal on mine which I
think unlikely yeah because I didn't
check Craigslist for for crazy for 15
years yeah that one's the most likely is
what we're trying to say right now yeah
I think so
I don't know how to decide between these
laws to between average Stephen and I
think here's what I think I think if the
back scratch bandit if somehow this gets
to that person I think the action is
innocuous enough to where that person
could be like oh yeah that was super
weird but it's fine
look thanks for apologizing yeah whereas
like this guy [ __ ] average Steven
those those two made up by lunch
I think so yeah I don't think she's
looking I think she was probably irate
like there is a parallel universe while
we're reading it totally incorrectly we
don't the context and she was like super
uplifted by whatever he actually said to
her but in my head this would be the one
that I would be like no [ __ ] that dude
yeah yeah like you said I've heard her
boyfriend made up by launch and they
awesome sex that night so I think so
from most to least it would be it would
be Barry backscratcher I'm rooting for
back special
and then Stephen yeah that's so I'm also
rooting for back scratcher though that's
the one that I want to work I want that
that man to know that she was sorry
Linda Linda from HR it's a problem with
a charge than what this Robin jar I
should know better I also like that it
wasn't rubbing it was scratching yeah
right which was also less affectionate
more once again a little more like if
I'm vomiting over the toilet
somebody's scratching my back in a
toilet and a stranger like scratched my
back or like help I probably would be
completely fine yeah probably like I
completely understand why you're doing
this and I appreciate it thank you can
you hold my hand once as an underage
drinker in the in the late 90s I had
like the long stage and I wish somebody
had been there what if you get really
drunk and you find yourself throwing up
here the last two times that I vomited
from alcohol after the rooster teeth's
Christmas parties I felt fine the whole
night the next day I spent the entire
day mowing I feel like that's a feeling
it's a very Australian thing based on
the Australians that I know do you just
know I'm saying the drink all night
don't feel anything the night of and
then the next day feels sick off but
it's just weird cuz it's not like
because like we drank pretty heavily at
a bunch of different parties outside of
that it's just funny that's the two in a
row or the recipient and the two were I
wonder if it's because it's really cold
it's like December in Texas and it's
pretty chilly like maybe like my logic
is like I'd do this and I don't call me
oh yeah except for that one [ __ ]
party every year where I'm like outside
it's also Austin they put barbecue sauce
at everything did you do the goon bag
thing yeah dude what's good good story
I've never done it but I it's one of its
my favorite piece of Australian lore
when you become old enough to drink and
it's your birthday they
take the wine in a box out of the thing
it's called a goon it's just like a
bladder and it's just the bladder and
they hang it up on the spinny I've
explained those to you Oh what is hope a
spinny clotheslines they they look like
old TV antennas or like upside down
umbrella 'z but they're for drying
clothes and they spin and they hang the
goon bags from the thing and they spin
them and everybody like just like oh
yeah you it's like I spin the bottle'
situation what you like pour it in your
mouth then you spin it I know this
sounds like a scene like Blade 2 but
it's blood it's about the vampires are
at a rave yeah like there's blood oh
it's the goon you have like that to me
sounds sexy it's not sexy I don't find
vampire sexy yeah they'll do for me I
know it's a thing like Anne Rice made
like a [ __ ] milli off I okay I think
vampire is a sexy based on well those
they're just extremely good-looking I
mean that's just
I do the ground and also he close I also
just find Kate Beckinsale really
attractive sexy that's like it's like
how there are fast zombies and slow
zombies like Kate Beckinsale vampires
and then other yeah it was very exciting
Moni why can people find you now you can
find me on all the social media at make
biggity MCB IgG ITT why I'm at a Carboni
on everything CIA are Bo and I and then
every Wednesday on starwars.com or the
Star Wars YouTube and the podcast is we
have concerns calm is the still most
YouTube just youtube.com slash something
yeah can you believe it oh you guys know
that I am at Charl Ana's art it's my
name in the middle chars oh I think you
guys were listening this week we'll have
a next another episode in a couple weeks
we'll see